hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well there's a very
strong religious motif that runs
throughout epictetus discourses and it's
not simply window dressing or something
optional it really is a key part of his
entire perspective and so he sees the
human being as being a part of God as
being the creature of God is being in a
certain sense of friend or a child of
God and one of the things that he
references and a number of points
particularly in book four is this this
issue of willing or choosing what it is
that God wills now of course Epictetus
does not have something exactly like
what later thinkers are going to call
the faculty will following to us but in
a Faculty of choices he understands that
the prior ASIS is pretty close to them
and he uses some other terminology as
well that I should probably signal very
quickly since in translation sometimes
this is going to be overlooked because
we're using the same word will or or
want so there's a Greek verb the lane
and when when epictetus is talking about
you know willing or wishing
or hiring what it is that God desires
he's using that word thumbing and that
means to want something - to prefer that
to - you know wish that to be the case
it's very much you know connected with
this notion of pro races from a races is
is a noun which comes from the verb Ryan
which means to to take something before
another thing so these are connected up
with each other another thing that the
Greens would use that you see that
makita's using as well where these you
know terms like hey con meaning
willingly you know we would say
voluntarily or you know by one's own
free choice and then you know aqua not
not so right so all that said what is
this stuff about willing what it is that
God wills now here's a passage from
chapter for what for which we're we're
going to come back to in a moment he
says do keep in remembrance your general
principles he's talking about stoic dog
model there you know the things you're
supposed to keep in mind so that it'll
help you think things up properly what
is mine what is not mine what has been
given me and then he asks what does God
will that I do now what does he not will
what does God want for me to do
presumably God has my best interests at
heart got God for epictetus and the
Stoics is a providential God God
rational more rational than I am in a
certain respect yon even my wrath limits
of rationality is capacity to understand
God's rationality so God is not going to
want for me crazy mad stuff as a matter
of fact the Stoics are going to say that
when the gods are depicted as you know
commanding things that are actually you
know not good for a person to do those
are just a lethargy have to be you know
understood in an allegorical way so God
is God wants for people certain things
and he also chooses nothing's choosing
he says a little while ago it was God's
will for you to be at leisure to
converse with yourself to write about
these things to read to listen to
prepare yourself you had sufficient time
for that
that was how do you know that that was
God's will because that was what you
were actually given that's that's what
happened you've got to go to school you
got to study Epictetus you got to study
with the patinas if you were back in
ancient Greece right patitos guys to
study was Missoni as Rufus now however
God says to comment length to the
contest show us what you have learned
how you have trained yourself how long
how long will you exercise alone now the
time has come for you to discover
whether you're one of the athletes who
deserve victory or belong to the number
of those who travel about the world that
are everywhere defeated meaning that at
a certain point God not only wants for
the the stoic to study stoic philosophy
but to put it in the application and God
would like for the person to be
successful it's up to the person whether
he or she really will be successful or
will be defeated by what they wrestled
with so what else can we say about this
notion of gods well well what does God
really want for human beings in the most
general sense we can understand this in
terms of what God gave us so epictetus
will tell us at numerous points look God
gave us a ruling faculty now that's
actually the portion of the divine
within us and that's you know and you
can you can check out the other videos
on the ruling faculty and on you know
the probably racist
these are all really the same thing the
Faculty of rationality or reason the
Faculty of choice the prior racist these
are all the the hegemony on the ruling
faculty don gave us that as an integral
part of human nature he also would gave
us other things to a body you know threw
us into existence at a certain point in
time but the body is is
you know something divine the body is
actually kind of an encumbrance
Epicurious actually has to say at a
certain point look if I could have given
you better stuff I wouldn't I gave you
the best stuff I possibly could so what
does God want from us now that we've
been given this well these faculties or
faculty have been given to us in order
for us to develop them we don't come
into the world with all of our faculties
operating at their highest level the way
you know say a piece of hardware comes
right out of the package as a matter of
fact it's not even the case for computer
hardware these days you gotta upload a
bunch of drivers and put in the right
software and you know tinker around with
things and then the things break down
you got to go on the forums and find out
what whoa how does this happen
right there's cuz they're constantly
releasing shoddy
software and hardware that has to be
updated so maybe that's not the best
example but it's still more than that
human beings we have to learn how to be
more and more rational we have to use
the rationality that we have which is
imperfect to improve upon that
rationality likewise with our Faculty of
choice by the time that we start
thinking about man how do I unscrew up
this this personality that I seem to
have developed we've already got some
things we have to work on and we can use
the Faculty of choice to do that when
you need to develop and then rightly use
not just use but writing to use these
faculties and why what is the highest
purpose of a human being you might say
well it's to be free and to be happy
well along with that in a Victini you
goes this connection with the divine
governance what is that connection well
part of it is being spectators being
able to see it as a matter of fact it's
not just being a spectator about the
entire cosmos even to go to you know to
be in a crowd he says you should
in a crowd as being in a festival you go
to the festival and you you don't need
to worry about you know you know what's
going on oh it's heaven just just sit
back and watch be a spectator but that's
not all for human beings we have the
capacity at least to some degree to
understand the divine governance and
we're certainly in the most employment
respects you know for example the fact
that we've been given these these
faculties and going beyond that we have
the capacity to cooperate with to
partake in the divine governance this is
something that is according to that
vicki is unique to human beings among
all of the animals the other animals as
he says they're governed by you know the
way that God set things up and they use
appearances we are able to understand
and to modify appearances we are able to
understand and decide don't want to
cooperate with or fight against the
divine governments what else does he
tell us he says that God wants us not to
claim things outside of the Faculty of
choice why is this guy being punitive
with us and saying look I'm gonna give
you a little bit of freedom but I don't
want you to use too much of it no God
wants what is actually best for us God
wants us to confine our faculty of
choice to this sort of reflexive
relation where it's working upon itself
and seeing how we use external things
because that is indeed what is best for
us that will make us happy that will
render us you know people who are able
to get along with in this this divine
and human community so what does he
actually have to say about that there's
two great passages that I want to call
your attention to one is in chapter 4 he
says there is but one way to serenity
and that you should keep this thought
ready for use at dawn
and by day and
and that is to yield up all claim to the
things that lie outside of the sphere of
the moral purpose or the Faculty of
choice to regard nothing as your own
possession to surrender everything to
God to fortune to you know everything to
the supervision of those persons who
even God has made supervisors even if
they're jerks he doesn't say that here
you know that's something he says many
other places then to devote yourself to
one thing only that which is your own
that which is free from hindrance and to
read referring your reading to this end
and so to write and so to listen that is
sort of an ideal of what we have to do
but what goes along with that well one
thing one notion is if we're in a
particular relationship where you know
we have a parent telling us what to do
or there's laws that that govern our
city we should actually obey those laws
because God placed us in the situation
where those things are are telling us
what to do now of course they go against
injustice
you know then we don't have to follow
them but we we have to be ready to
accept the consequences in that case in
Chapter three he says another thing he
says I should not claim anything not
properly not not body or office or
reputation nothing in short nor does God
wish me to claim them yeah he's so
desired he would have made them good for
me but as it is he has not so made them
therefore I cannot transgress any of his
commands guard her own good and
everything you do and for the rest be
content to take simply what has been
given up you in so far as you can make a
rational use of it and he says here's
the consequences if you don't if you if
you don't follow that if you don't
you're going to have bad luck and no
luck you'll be hampered and hindered
these are the laws he says that are sent
you from God these are his ordinances
and it is a
these you want to become an interpreter
you ought to subject yourself not the
laws of Marisa but serious sorry and
Casas the idea there is that there is
indeed some sort of divine law it's not
one where you know God gave it on top of
Mount Sinai or through the mouths of
priests or anything like that
it's rather one that we can come to
understand through reason God built it
into the fabric of the universe and into
the fabric of our rationality but they
are the laws nonetheless they they
manifest the divine will which is for
our own good when we decide we want to
go against us against it which we are
left free to do we suffer as a result
and we don't suffer because God you know
throws lightning bolts down at us or
sends a plague we suffer because when we
preoccupy ourselves with things that
really aren't our business we are
setting ourselves up for trouble another
thing that he says in chapter 24 of book
3 is that we we should if we want to
will what it is that God wills we ought
to fulfill our roles and relationships
in an orderly way rightly following God
this is a very interesting passage just
find it here yeah so he says whatever
station you assigned to me I don't that
10,000 times the Socrates says or ever I
abandoned them wherever you want me to
be in Rome Athens and Thebes or Galliera
only remember me there if you send me to
a place where men have no means of
living in accordance with nature all the
part of this life not in disobedience
view but as though you were sounding for
me the recall
I don't abandon you be far be that for
me but I perceive that thou has no need
of me so if there is vouchsafed
of living in accordance with nature I'm
going to seek no other place than that
in which I am or other men than those
who are now my associates
Epictetus is talking here about
accepting the conditions that we've been
placed in as those that are willed by
God and then making the best of them if
there are conditions in which we cannot
live then we depart from this look as if
God is you're calling us back back to
the basic elements that we were composed
of but if it is possible to live with
these human beings in these
circumstances then I will focus on that
and stayed stayed true to God
and he says you know how many how how
does God want us to do things as a free
man but also as God's servant as one who
perceived God's commands and
prohibitions so these are these are
quite important ways of thinking about
how we ought to be here there is like I
said a very strong religious component
to what epictetus is saying but it's not
the sort of religion that we tend to
think of you know as revealed religion
instead this is something where God is
quite literally not just out there in
the universe but also within us within
our rationality helping to guide us so
epictetus says that we should widdle or
we should choose what it is that God
wills for us and he gives us some
interesting ways of understanding just
what that would be for a human being